mmm 10 seconds
hi and welcome to gaben max is 100
seconds though the real question is when
is gaben max is one convert sec the real
question is how excited we are to talk
about the sixth and final season of JJ
rawlings unlost we are this excited for
the series premiere I can't wait to see
my old friends again Jack and Kate
Vincent and baby we're in this is the
last chance for the show to answer all
the questions that's been asking for
five years it's like the show's always
asking questions and shut up the season
is this last chance to just shut up what
am I in school when we last left or
castaways scientist Daniel Faraday told
our pals the only way to save the island
was to detonate a hydrogen bomb and send
them all back in time before it ever
happened Juliet slammed a rock down on
the bomb and everything went to white
the castaways save the island they've
gone back in time or did they I think
they have I think it's clear with the
going to white that they're traveling
through time before any of it ever
happened or did it no it didn't happen I
when it went to white everyone hi and
welcome to Gavin Max's 100 seconds this
week we're talking about the premiere of
the brand new series that no one's seen
yet lost it looks like a pretty
straightforward adventure series about a
group of normal people lost on a normal
Island I don't know why that I've got a
pretty good feeling the show will never
just introduce characters or concepts we
never hear from again we are this
exciting I bet there will never be a
show called lost my beanie babies are
worth a million dollars